hey guys i just want to say thank you
very much this is our little uh youtube
plaque here i just wanted to open this
bad boy up and show you
what this thing looks like
i've never done an unboxing video you
got a nice little letter here talks
about just how far we've come y'all came
there with you guys thank you very much
here it is
oh snap there it is y'all
a hundred thousand youtube subscribers
we did that in about a year guys thank
you so much for your support thank you
for the love night pants nation yard as
[ __ ] this one's gone on the wall
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media i continue to thank you guys for
continuing to support me in the show and
the tour the night pants nation tour is
continuing to roll out there we're
having a great time la jolla i'll be
there december 15th through the 17th and
austin coming to texas austin coming
there y'all january 6th through the 8th
go to ryansickler.com for tickets sign
up for the email list and again too if
you're watching the show thank you and
hit that subscribe it means nothing to
you and everything to us i promise you
it means a lot to us the patreon
i just love my [ __ ] job i'm
highlighting the lowlights with you all
so honeydew with you all it's five bucks
a month on patreon you get the honeydew
a day early ad free and if you sign up
for a year you get over a month free all
right it's a great show i mean we've
like i've said every week talked to some
people we solved the cold case i say we
solved he saw he just told us about it
but i like to say we solved that [ __ ]
uh we got a dude that was
paralyzed in the [ __ ] wilderness that
slept overnight paralyzed for 30 [ __ ]
hours not in his house in the wilderness
all right so
that's the deal uh check it all out and
uh you know what we do here we highlight
the low lights over here we bring a
little light to the darkness and these
are the stories behind the storytellers
all right ladies and gentlemen
for the first time here on the honeydew
please welcome steven garza welcome to
the honeydew what's up everybody hey
thank you so much for having me i really
appreciate it man i know a long time
listen this is a i want to say this now
this is a this is an important episode
we've never you're not you've got to sit
up on that mic or you're going gonna get
yelled at especially with what we're
gonna talk about okay there we go um
we're gonna talk about a school shooting
you're a school shooting survivor
yeah i've never looked at it that way i
guess so yeah yeah you are you're a
survivor of a school shooting and we've
never
we've never done an episode not a
patreon episode not a regular honeydew
of anyone that's been involved in a
school shooting so i know
it's gonna be a difficult thing to talk
about i'm sure uh
so please before we do though promote
plug everything you want and then we're
going to get into it yeah so before i
just want to plug my instagram and
youtube channel so it's steven garza
s-t-e-v-e-n-g-a-r-z-a joke
that's my instagram handle and steven
garza comedy for
youtube that's it man all right so
you're a doorman at the comedy store
that's how i met you in comedy yeah and
i know we talked about this a while ago
you approached me and told me that and i
was like
holy [ __ ] i definitely want to do this
and i appreciate your patience we've
undergone a lot of changes here at the
studio and no i understand you said it
it's it's one of those things
yeah absolutely it's it's just a story
that i think
people need to hear and you know what's
it's it's interesting because
everybody knew about it at the time this
happened in 2001. nobody remembers it
now
you know that's very sad and it's sad
because there are so many of them you
literally start saying and you know i
don't even mean to be in sensitive time
which one was that exactly you know and
you're like well that was the one where
then you're like oh my god that one yeah
yeah so before we get there can you
briefly tell me about
where you're from originally grew up and
all that and and how we get into
this school story so i'm from a city
called santee california it's san diego
county so east county area san diego
about 20 minute drive from downtown
uh very i would say
i don't know suburbs you know getting
more rural the further you get out uh a
nice neighborhood i think we got a bad
rap in the late 90s mtv did a story on
white supremacy on the specific city
and that gave us a bad rap but a lot of
it was untrue so people hear santee they
may think of that if they've heard that
at all but it was a nice
it was a nice town and still is
with some [ __ ] like everything sure
right they gave a bad name i guess and
then you know the media picked up on
that and ran with it so this was late
90s okay
and are you
only child so i have i have two younger
brothers an older sister one of my
brother both brothers in san diego now
sister just moved to iowa what's your
age difference were any of you in the
same school at the same time so i was uh
i was four years ahead of my
second uh
brother he was he was he started the
year i graduated got it and then after
that he
see he was there four years my brother
was a freshman while he was a senior
and sister was already graduated by this
time and we're parents together
separated parents are not together
anymore they've been married we're
married
at the time they were yeah yeah yeah
they have a very it was a strange
marriage they were together but never
any love in that marriage it's kind of a
sad situation a business proposal sure
so what did your what did your father do
for a living he uh he worked for
commercial refrigeration okay so fixing
ice machines and you know
giant warehouses and what about your mom
mom was a legal secretary for the state
your mom was a legal secretary all right
okay so
this is 2001 we're getting to now you're
in right high school you're a junior
senior junior you're a junior at what's
the high school high school is santana
all right santana high
and
i mean look it's yes this is crazy there
have already been so many school
shootings prior to this so the questions
i sort of want to know are
did you did were there rumors of this
coming where there's anything anyone
sort of knew and didn't take
uh seriously that they should have you
know that sort of thing because
you know all these things happen yeah
there were so many of them there was
actually well
you gotta remember 2001 this is the
first major school shooting coming after
columbine
so i don't remember hearing much about
school shootings until up till columbine
oh then i'm wrong okay i'm sorry 2001
was the
so the second one then in my opinion
before the monday shooter and a few that
you had in the 70s and 80s but but to me
it was columbine and then things kind of
snowballed crazy after that
i'm sorry then i didn't i thought this
was later no so it was just this was
maybe i mean that's what i'm saying
there's so many of them i can't i don't
even remember when or anything the sandy
hook all like good lord yeah right but
so and it was also interesting because
so there was there was columbine and
then we were about a year later santana
school shooting and then a couple miles
down the road kind of a rival high
school there was another school shooting
two weeks later so it all happened this
little town and just as i said you there
were some white supremacy rumors and it
just exploded with you know the media on
that knowing that oh two school
shootings within a month plus white
supremacists with white supremacy yeah
and so
left over to today santee gets a real
bad rap
especially in the san diego area people
know or assume it's bad from it's still
stemming from you know what took place
back then and this yeah so this was i
would say the first major school
shooting after columbus okay
so what were there any rumors or
anything that was floating around yeah
it's funny because the rumors always
start to cut afterwards right people are
like oh well so-and-so said this was
gonna happen nobody reported it and so
yeah there were definitely rumors and i
can remember a specific entrance with uh
there was a lot of fights happening at
the school at that time kids i don't
know they're just angry and to me that
was just happened at every high school
but apparently for whatever reason
everybody was fighting at this this
particular month a couple months leading
up to the school shooting and i remember
my dad saying he's like man was there
gonna be a school shooting or something
he said that yeah just joking around
a couple months later
you know it happened can you never
forget that can you walk us through that
day like the moment you get up in the
morning walk me through the whole
[ __ ] well just like they say it was i
remember it was sunny it was a morning
just like any other morning just like
they always say
i don't remember i couldn't tell you
okay yeah i just know it was 2001 i
remember i had a counselor's appointment
earlier that day so i had to go into the
counselor's office and my grades were
always awful so it was like hey the type
of meeting we're like hey pick it up or
you know you remember is that day more
detailed in your life than maybe
anything else like do you remember what
you ate for breakfast do you remember
what you how you got to school that
morning and you say you got there
earlier because you had this appointment
other than that no i just remember kind
of like i guess highlights i don't know
what you would call them uh bits and
pieces come back to me yeah i guess
and now us so one thing i wanted to say
before we get too far is that there were
rumors uh that this was going to
apparently this kid told people he was
going to do it the day before
and the friends and even a grown-up at
the time he told it to his friends and
to the growing up never reported it so
they got driven out of town after that
really they were yeah lynch mobbed out
of there because people were pissed what
do you mean this kid told you he was
gonna do it and you being an adult you
just sat on it and one of those kids
that he told like i think there's a
group of like four or five that he was
hanging he told i was going to do this
went to the high school we were talking
was called granite hills arrival high
school so he and that's when the school
shooting took place so that kid was in
two school shootings within a month no
yeah i got driven out of santee
pushed over to this school
yeah it's like bro
i want nothing to do with it
you talk about born under a bad
two school shootings in two weeks right
dude he holds the record tell me there's
no way
that's terrible
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah you're not even
processed the first no [ __ ] trauma no
you're not even like what it's happening
but you had to think like he had to have
known when they started hearing that pop
pop he's like oh i know where this is
going you know what i mean by then he
was a veteran yeah you know how to take
it knew how to handle it but from what i
heard he got a bunch and and this was
all speculative but i heard he got a
bunch of crap pushed over to that high
school and you know people tease them
hey don't bring your hate crimes over
here
to our school and uh and it i guess in a
way it followed him [ __ ]
all right so tell me what happened that
day
so this was okay i remember we had fur
we had like a block system and you would
have your first class and after that
class you would have a break in between
your next class it was like a not lunch
but a 20-minute break before that where
would you go the cafeteria outside
yeah yeah so we had two big quads which
were grass areas giant grass areas uh
and the big quad is where most people
hung out and i would say i guess the
jocks you know more of the more popular
kids were in that area and then you'd go
to the small quad had two hallways that
would lead into the small grass squad
and that was more of your artsy area
punks rocker stuff like that
and i was in the in the main quad and
like i said there's two hallways that
lead in and out of the quads the only
two ways you can get from one way and
the classrooms line all of that
and what happened was i was at the very
south side of the north quad
and the bell rings so the break time's
over we just everybody was hanging out
what time of day is this which would
have been probably 9 30. i think that's
what it took about it's about 9 30. the
bell rings we have a three bell system
first bell means get to class breaks
over second bell means you've got a
minute left uh if you don't make it
within that minute then you got to go to
something called lockout which is where
you don't get attendance for the day and
you've got to sit in a room by yourself
which was
looking back on it what was that doing
to anybody to the kids that that's i
wanted that
the first bell rang and for whatever
reason that day i said you know i
thought i remember thinking to myself i
don't i just don't want to go i don't
want to go to class today
and the shooting actually took place at
the end of the hallway that i had to
walk through to get to my class right
there was a bathroom it emptied out into
a bathroom and that's where the shooting
took place the shooter was standing in
front of the bathroom because he was
using it as coverage so he'd go in there
reload come back out
right he reloaded he had a revolver 22.
he's going to say i watched your hand
motion do this so he had a revolver he
had a revolver yeah i remember i'm right
here i mean i was right there for
everything second bell rings means
you've got like a minute or two minutes
to get to class and it's still i'm going
ah i just i don't want to go meanwhile i
normally would have left after that
second bell would have put me right in
front of the bathroom with a school
because i had to go right past there to
get to my class so what put me face to
face with the shooter had i gone when i
normally did but for whatever reason
not today i'm just not feeling it
and i'd say a couple seconds after that
second bell ring i slowly started to
make my way
down the hallway where the because the
shooting took place in the hallway
with a friend my childhood friend john
that i grew up with we were kind of
slacking off that day and we started
making our way down the hall
slowly described the whole is it locker
line
yeah locker lined hallway
uh and it was like herding cattle in
between classes and how why would you
say like 20 feet yes 20 by 10. yeah
probably about not much bigger than this
so maybe 15 20 feet you're shoving how
many kids pouring through this
especially those last minute loser kids
that don't want to go to class we're all
scrambling because we you know you don't
get attendance for the day so it was
really like herding cattle
and this kid knew that that's the
problem that's what was scary is it that
he picked that place because he knew he
was going to pick people off it'd be
super easy we wouldn't have to aim
as as the second bell rings i wait a
couple minutes i start to make my way to
the hallway with my friend john
all of a sudden i see everybody running
out of the hallway opposite direction of
which i want to go in right and they all
had that normally when that happens it
means there's a fight so as a 17 year
old boy we wanted to go watch we ran to
the crowd
opposite direction but it didn't make
sense to me at the time screaming no i
remember this one tall blonde chick for
some reason i'll never forget she had
this look on her face i can't describe
other than just
absolute terror and no one yelled run or
anything nobody knew what was going on
they taught mob mentality everyone's
going this way we go this way no we went
the opposite i mean them all of them
correct they're going and you guys are
going to go [ __ ] upstream because we
thought everybody right but it didn't
make sense why is everybody walking away
from a fight normally everybody
gravitates towards it so it wasn't
processing and i didn't hear that the
first few rounds
so i didn't know what was going on until
i came in the hallway then i looked down
at the end of the hallway there's a kid
holding his stomach laying on the ground
right so this was right in front of the
bathroom where the guy was shooting
everybody was exiting the hallway i was
coming into the hallway to see what was
going on thinking it was a fight
i thought wow this guy got stabbed
that's insane it was just a fist fight
this guy got stabbed
the shooter comes back out of the
bathroom i guess he had gone in to
reload
and that's when he shot into the hallway
that i was standing in and there was a
soda machine at the end of the hallway
where uh where i was standing me and my
friend were right there
the first shot when he came back after
reloaded was so loud in that hallway
because gun law you know gunshots are
loud and that's why i say this all the
time people with the i would
yeah
listen if you're in a small ass [ __ ]
hallway in your home and you got to
defend yourself [ __ ] yeah if you've got
a gun man take that [ __ ] out but
just know
that there's gun powder that burns your
eyes the gun kicks it's loud as [ __ ]
your your ears are gonna ring your eyes
might burn like exactly what happens a
shot literally hopefully to get one if
you're in a space like that and i don't
think a lot of people think that they
think they can just come in and [ __ ]
it's not does not work that way no can i
ask you this real quick did you know the
shooter did you know who he was uh we
hung in
not really no class not a risk theater
no but i knew kids that hung out with
them this burnout group was he was
hanging out
he was a freshman whoa he's a freshman
yeah he's a little punk freshman man
that was trying to be cool i'll get into
that in a second
uh trying to impress his friends is what
it turned out to be it wasn't a bully
situation it was him trying to be cool
to fit in with the older burnouts so let
me ask you this do you when a bullet
goes by you like that do you hear it
i don't know i mean i don't mean what
you hit i mean you get that
you know what so what i hung out with
the
the uh soda machine the first first
bullet i went to my knees for whatever
reason you got to remember the shooter
was like 300 feet away there's no
charging him to stop it you know there's
no only thing i could do was run away
from the bullet so
i just want to make that clear i dropped
to my knee for some reason i guess it
was that loud i don't know if i was if i
turned to run and i tripped or something
but my hand was against the soda machine
and as i put my hand on the sodium
machine the shooter
i don't think he was aiming for me but
you know sometimes i think he was he
shot the sona machine that i was holding
my hand against and i know it not only
did i hear it but the the sono machine
was never replaced it was there when we
came back on the campus so you go back
and you realize you go back hey uh e6 is
not available all right
the best they did was a couple months
later they did a sloppy pain over job of
where the bullet hit so the mark and the
indent was right there and what i'm
saying is i know it hit them sewing
machines not only did i hear it but you
can see the indent that it hit where it
went through the metal and bent the cage
you know though so sorry the soda
machine had a cage around it and it
busted that all up got it that was not
so
close to your hand would you say that
bullet i mean with this
within a foot now god but he shot again
and that hit the stucco that the that
the soda machine was butted up against
stuck a wall when you hit that stucco
wall that stucco blows back into your
face so that blinded you know me for a
second because it the blowback was so
intense and at this point where you are
how many people would you say i know i
know you probably don't know the answer
to my questions because but what
a handful of people back there like
trying to get out so the the first wave
of people are already out now okay first
wave her out and remember i came in
after that first grade i didn't hear it
and we thought there was a fight
i forgot to mention the kid laying on
the ground with his stomach i thought he
had gotten stabbed right
the shooter went in there reloaded comes
back out and that's when i make my
entrance into the hall as soon as he
comes back out he shoots again i see the
guy who fell on the ground holding his
stomach he got up and ran he got away
yeah and at that point i knew
he knew something was up i still hadn't
processed that it was a gun still in the
process that i'm being shot at or people
around me shot at
uh so that's when yeah he reloaded came
out he shot the soda machine then he
shot the wall against me
and my buddy i was telling you it was
with his hands were all cut up and
bleeding from the stucco on the wall
at that time i remember
turning turning around after seeing this
guy
uh
come out of the hallway he was just and
not aiming by the way just picking
people off there i don't think he was
aiming for anybody specifically or
targeting anybody at that time i just
turned around and ran and i'll never
forget there was a there was a special
needs guy next to me
i remember thinking you know should i
carry him but he was running just as
fast as i was so
yeah i was like oh he's good like [ __ ]
i'll never forget man the coolest kid
his name was robert we had pe together
but the thing that
yeah you don't need to help me at all
man i gave him that look because you
know you're like
what's the right thing
but the the thing it's nice you to even
consider wanting to help someone else in
that situation yeah i didn't but you
know i thought about it yeah
athletic greens the health and wellness
company that makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple i've been taking
athletic greens i take it every morning
we have them here at the studio as well
look i don't always eat well i eat late
i eat garbage i eat fast food and i need
to get the nutrients that i need so i
take the athletic greens i got the
powder i put it in a little water bottle
with me i take it where i walk i take it
when i'm going to the gym and i love it
it starts my day off right i know i'm
getting the nutrients i need and it's
delicious all right so
with so many stressors in life it's
difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and give our bodies
the nutrients it needs to thrive ag-1 by
athletic greens is the category-leading
superfood product that brings
comprehensive and convenient daily
nutrition to everybody to help each of
us be at our best they simplify the path
to better nutrition by giving you the
one thing with all the best things one
tasty scoop of ag-1 contains 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods food-sourced
ingredients including a multivitam
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more in one convenient daily
serving the special blend of high
quality bioavailable ingredients in a
scoop of ag-1 work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet support
energy and focus aid with gut health and
digestion and support a healthy immune
system effectively replacing
multiple products or pills with one
healthy delicious drink join the
movement of athletes moms dads rookies
first timers and everyone in between to
make it easy athletic greens is going to
give you an immune supporting free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew to take control of your health
and give a g one a try the holidays are
right around the corner if you want help
prepping for your parties and family
get-togethers all while supporting a
more sustainable local food system check
out imperfect foods and perfect foods is
a grocery delivery service offering an
entire line of sustainable groceries
that taste delicious and reduce waste
plus your order will arrive on the same
day each week on average imperfect foods
customers save six to eight pounds of
food from lesser outcomes with every
order and unlike on-demand delivery
companies imperfect delivers weekly by
neighborhood a unique model that
produces 25 to 75 percent fewer missions
than individual trips to the grocery
store plus say goodbye to packaging
guilt and perfect foods is the only
national grocery delivery company to
make it easy to return your packaging
after every order i've got a whole i've
gotten two orders now of imperfect foods
and it's fantastic i mean i've gotten
eggs i had bacon what else i had
vegetables we took and made stuffed
peppers out of it it was delicious right
now imperfect foods is offering my
listeners 20 off your first four orders
when you go to imperfectfoods.com and
use promo code honeydew again 20 off
your first four orders that's up to an
80 value at
imperfectfoods.com when you use the
promo code honeydew imperfectfoods.com
and use code honeydew we deserve to know
what we're putting in our bodies and why
especially when it comes to something we
take every day rituals clean vegan
friendly multivitamin is formulated with
high quality nutrients in a bioavailable
form your body can actually use what you
won't find are sugars gmos major
allergens synthetic fillers and
artificial colorants plus the fresh
taste and delayed release capsule design
make taking your vitamins easy i'm a
ritual taker i ritually take ritual
vitamins every day i take the
multivitamin it does have a clean like
minty fresh taste it's pretty
interesting too you look in the capsule
you can see everything that's going on
in there and
i've been looking for a multivitamin uh
for a while now that wasn't you know
full of garbage and ritual is it you'll
always know what nutrients you're taking
where they come from thanks to rituals
one of a kind visible supply chain your
multivitamins are delivered right to
your door every month with free shipping
always and you can start snooze or
cancel your subscription anytime and if
you don't love ritual within your first
month they'll refund your first order
okay get key nutrients without the bs
ritual is offering my listeners 10 off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com honeydew to start your ritual
today now let's get back to the duke and
so we ran together to the parking lot we
ran so from the hallway we ran through
the big quad into the parking lot now at
that point that you're running out are
you still hearing the pops yeah at that
point you're hearing but screams at that
point or people realize i hear any
screams uh one thing i do remember is
thinking i'm gonna get shot in the back
because we didn't know i was thinking
there's somebody on the roof along with
him right so i know if you don't know
right he's the one shooter good point so
the whole time i'm thinking man i'm
gonna get shot in the back running to
the park and that's what i thought was
gonna happen
yeah god it's crazy even to think that
maybe he is maybe he's flushing you all
out that way and there's other people
that way right that goes through your
mind [ __ ] i'm sure [ __ ] for some reason
yeah i thought okay there's a guy up on
the roof and he's gonna snipe me now
that's kind of what was going through my
head one thing i'll never forget when
they talk about heroes in a situation
like that we had these guys called narcs
which were just police on campus right
they weren't cops but they were there to
break up fights and make sure everything
went smoothly did they very well remarks
no no they were always normally big
dudes i knew how to handle themselves i
think they were going to be police
officers eventually they started there
this one guy i'll never forget he had
these rad tattoos all the way down his
arm like a spiral
he was running towards the shooting
everybody running away but this guy
running towards it man and you i mean
you got to remember at this time what a
hero really is everybody wants out of
there not him man he's going towards the
face of danger i'll never forget that
how brave you'd have to be
to do something like that
another one of the narcs i didn't have
funny because you guys went to thinking
it was a fight which is dumb yeah this
guy now's running because he knows what
it is
yeah exactly yes
there's the fine line between dumb and
brave
oh [ __ ] okay
all right so i have to ask how many
people did it died did that guy that got
shot in the stomach do you know i never
died later i don't think that was the
kid that died i don't think so i never
found out who it was the two two died
fifteen were shot all together two died
yeah man you gotta remember he was just
picking people off in the hallway it was
there's no strategy behind it other than
just fire and hit what you can
and the guy it was this was when video
cameras are still kind of new as far as
portable cameras go
hey just some techie kid had a camera on
him
no way hid in a classroom which was
overlooking the bathroom the guy was
shooting at filmed it we never got the
footage by the way the cops still have
it they've never released it film the
shooting the shooter was smiling
laughing as he was pulling the trigger
killing kids in the hallway smiling
imagine that level of insanity and well
i guess we'll get to this later but like
this 14 too he's 14th grade yeah yeah
he's trying to get out of jail right now
wait let's get into that yeah all right
so you guys run out of this school
and you're in the where did you say the
quad you're back at the quad so i ran
back into the large quad okay shooting
took place in the small quad uh at the
end of the hallway i was on the opposite
end of the hallway in the large quad are
you worried that he's walking your way
yeah or so the whole time you're running
i think he's behind me or somebody's on
the roof ready so
as fast as you're running you can't get
far enough away fast enough
you have no idea what's around you a
bullet can go for yeah and then you
think someone's gonna come up in front
of me and they're gonna block me off
here luckily i was able to make it to
the
parking lot where most everybody but you
got to remember man
we're kids at this time nobody knows
what's going on right and i'm sure the
police maybe if they've been called it
they just got caught so they're not
there yeah you're just a group of kids
and teachers probably faculty in a
parking lot i got into my car in the
parking lot and actually asked myself do
i need to go back to class you're not
processing sure what's going on like i
got i guess i'll just wait for a second
then i'll go back to class that's how i
just didn't process at that moment
eventually everybody started we got in
our car and we just left and i'll never
remember driving home on the main street
that the that the high school was on a
cop just flying past me in the opposite
direction that's when i knew oh man this
is this is real
and what happened the raid the guy the
kid got caught
there was an off-duty officer on campus
that day just happened to be there i
guess after he had reloaded once or
twice the cop
heard the commotion 901 calls were
already made he went in there to kind of
figure out what was going on and then
call for backup so if it wasn't for him
who knows how many more kids would have
been shot or would have
died did they kill him
oh no you said no trying to get out of
jail all right we'll come back we'll
come back to that so
all right you leave and then what you go
home where do you i went home
i'll never forget the message i left my
mom at her work where i go hey mom uh
something happened at school but i'm
okay and then i hung up
it didn't go in detail oh my god
and she later told me like what were you
thinking man
and she because she you know it was all
it was world news at the time er the way
you know it was at world news is because
not only was on every station every
night
but people from other countries were
calling
family members of mine knowing that they
lived in the area they had a nephew or a
grandson or someone that lived in that
area and
from england or you know in europe and
so they were getting all this as well
damn that's how i mean it was huge
that's why it blows my mind that nobody
remembers it even
even now
so yeah like i said i thought this was
down the line of these school shootings
and interesting it's pretty much the
second one i would say it was probably
the second one in the ufc heavily
profile yeah that's why i wonder out of
all the school shootings we have now how
many people are going to remember these
you know 20 years from now because this
was just as big
we didn't have social media at the time
but it was on every channel for weeks
cnn that's all they covered
every night
so who's the first person you actually
get to talk to about it like to unload
on you calling other friends at school
are you checking on people like what's
happening with that's right what
happened was after i had driven away
i went home which wasn't very far what
happened there's a strip mall across the
street from the high school i had a
grocery store like a dell taco jack in
the box
things like like that was pretty big and
everybody gathered there so i got home
and we already it was already on the
news by the time i had gotten home and i
was with one of my my other friend had
made his way john that was in high
school with uh that was in the hallway
with made his way to my house and we
went back to the gathering place
thinking that's where we needed to be
because it was on the news like hey all
the kids are here finding out
everybody's okay everybody's accounted
for so we went into that and that's when
everybody the room was started going
around hey did you hear who it was did
you hear it was this it was it turned
out it was this burner i don't even want
to say his name some burnout kid [ __ ]
him i've never i cannot stand this kid
the interesting part is that
most school shooters killed themselves
or
before the shooting's over from what
i've seen at least right this was one of
the first ones where you could see
the steps being taken
to him going to prison
so
he was arrested
he was detained then he had his trial
then he has you know whatever [ __ ]
whatever
his appeal and you get to kind of follow
all the way along which also kind of
sucks because it still comes back up i
gotta i gotta hear about this guy
wanting to get out into prison another
thing he wants to be a cop last i heard
what
you don't you can't be no you can't be
you don't commit a double homicide
of children of children right and then
get to be a cop dumb doesn't he
understand he doesn't even if he gets
out he's never allowed to have a weapon
or anything no he's got felonies exactly
it's over
but also keep that [ __ ] in
prison
yes i mean a school shooting should be
life in prison if not death man you know
do us a favor and shoot yourself
[ __ ] please
save one save one for yourself yeah
please that's why i still to this day
you know like why don't you take
yourself out man yeah there's no i'm not
gonna shut it's here for you you almost
shot me in the face i mean he came a
foot and a half from shooting me in the
face
okay and you know
the older i get the harder that is to
deal with when i was a kid i just blew
it off but the more i do
i don't know
i bet you just i mean look i see [ __ ]
that freaks me out like
and i don't know if it's true i know
there's a lot of scare stuff out there
too but but like there was an article
that said something about
don't send your kids to school in shoes
that flash
because when they run they could see
that flash and i'm like oh my god like
this is what it's come to you gotta
think about that
so i um
i mean man my heart goes out to the
families and the victims and
you know that's the other thing they say
well how many dead well there's two dead
but how many shot
15 all together okay so 15 people this
is what they say oh 15 shot okay but we
don't realize that person might have
lost their [ __ ] hand yeah or the use
of their leg for the rest of their i'm
shot and i'm alive but also i lost a leg
or i don't have i have to wear a
colostomy bag i've got to breathe
through who knows what just you know
shot counts man not to mention the
psychological damage that you're gonna
have for the road i had a buddy who was
actually in the bathroom that the kid
the kid started the shooting in the
bathroom and then brought it out
yeah he was in there that's where the
first and uh uh the first kid died was
going to the bathroom
walked up behind him shot him killed him
that's where the shooting took place
nothing racially motivated bullying none
of that just uh mental illness clearly
she's laughing and [ __ ] you said smiling
trying to fit in with the with the wrong
crowd is from what i've gathered that's
it and that was the way and i'll get to
that in a second about why i think it
was that my friend was using the urinal
happen to know the shooter you knew the
guy that got shot yeah we were good
friends we played basketball together
baseball we were on you know sports
came up behind him going to the bathroom
and you know using the urinal shot him
in the neck
and
left him there to die he goes out in the
hallway to start shooting that's when i
come around the corner i get or this
might have been just before i come
around the corner the kid's crying or
moaning on the floor oh oh he turns
around tells him to shut up goes back to
shooting kids in the hallway
it's just that's how brutal this kid was
just your friend he told my friend to
shut up who was moaning on the ground he
bled out
no he lived actually yes he lived after
being shot in the neck in the neck yeah
holy [ __ ] out for months after that came
back with you know giant brace on his
head and you could see the the bullet
hole in his neck or the entrance that it
took they should put him next to the
coke machine
who wore it better
i'm going to this coke machine for
halloween [ __ ]
if i could oh man
oh my goodness
he's i haven't heard from him in you
know 20 years but uh last i heard he was
he had a kid on the way and he was
married so he's doing fine
any did you know any other people close
i knew another kid got shot in
in the lip i remember we grew up
together it was somehow entered
so he came back with just this giant lip
or yeah i just did it
or anything i don't remember blowing
teeth out no you just got lucky yeah
just look across your face yeah somehow
in through here and out that's gonna
blew his jaw exactly i mean inches holy
[ __ ] and he and that was just from
running like just these are straight
bullets flying through yeah that's the
other thing you don't think about this
guy's just spraying you don't think
about ricochet like she could bounce
here and shoot over that way yeah
someone made it home now this is a rumor
but it was a lot of people had had told
me about this someone made it home
didn't realize they were shot in the
lake until they got home adrenaline
right the adrenaline and so i do you do
know a couple other kids that got shot
one none of i didn't know the kids that
died so how did how did he get them
one kid was in the bathroom with my
friend uh and he just shot him in the
head
that kid died instantly in the bathroom
the other kid was in the hall imagine
you're just going to the bathroom and
then your lights go out that's it that's
it i think i don't even know what's
going on uh-uh i think about it all the
time all the time
and i do have some ptsd from it like i
don't like to be
for a long time i couldn't go into
schools that were indoors i just
couldn't do it i got up so many
questions how do you feel when the store
is packed every room in there very
back's always too old that shooting
happened on the on were you there that
night no i wasn't there that night yeah
but i heard that guy that was in the two
school shootings was there that night
this little legend continues he just
happened
man i appreciate you helping me fight
humor at this because this is crazy i
mean there's funny parts looking back on
you know it's a sad situation but you
gotta laugh at it dude you know
it's funny seeing people
that class get older and older and
seeing them develop families and yeah i
mean reunions all right wait well let's
go back let's go back all right so
someone in the lip guys apologize i know
i'm going very fast you don't owe any
but it's uh it's coming back to me and
i'm trying to get everything out so if
you're having a hard time following i'm
not okay i'm not we can go wherever you
want to go i'll reset us and we can go
again okay it's all good be yourself
please
um i want you to be and i couldn't
there's i mean i hope there's not a lot
of people out there that can
you know understand exactly what you're
talking about yeah but unfortunately
there probably are so
um i do have a friend well dan van
kirk's friend was involved in the vegas
shooting
um and a friend of mine her daughter was
in there and she had just left so
i've talked to some people about this
crazy [ __ ] but yeah i've never sat with
someone and talked about a school
shooting i mean that's the other thing
i'll never forget hearing this columbine
parent say you know someone said to them
wrong place right wrong time and she
said [ __ ] my kid was in school they
were exactly where they were supposed to
be
that [ __ ] day don't tell me wrong
place wrong time and i thought you know
what [ __ ] yeah yeah that's [ __ ]
wrong place wrong time that's where they
were supposed to be that day
so
um
going back to
someone getting the the people who died
you said the one boy and who was the
other person the other one i believe was
shot in the hall
he was shot was able to run around the
corner
so as i mentioned earlier i was at the
end of the hall i was on the left side
of the hall he ran around the right side
of the hall and apparently he collapsed
right there a teacher came out performed
cpr and he died in the teacher's arms
the teacher had jesus was at the had
been there he was like you know
20 some odd years
i just i think he
later on i learned he had like six
shrinks after this he just couldn't get
over the kid died in his arms i mean i
don't think he ever recovered i don't
know how you could uh uh
so that's where the second kid uh that
was a rant so randy gordon who was a
senior and
i believe brian zucker was a he was a
freshman who wanted to be a stunt double
which was funny because i remember
hearing rumors about this freshman who
if you gave him a dollar he would run
into a poll head first
and so we would bring dollars and try
and you know have them run into pools
holy [ __ ] so just great you know two of
the most innocent kids at that school
you know everyone's innocent oh yeah
they're all innocent they're in school
yeah let me ask you um do you know who
the worst the person who that survived
but worst damage
probably in a wheelchair or anyone i
don't remember anybody being in a
wheelchair i think my buddy who got shot
in the neck was the worst one that i can
remember but he's recovered now he
recovered yeah everybody i know had a
full recovery i knew another guy shot in
the butt
he
yeah he recovered that's probably the
best place you could get shot right i
don't know i would say it's the
fleshiest in muscle somebody else got
the kid who got shot through the lip he
had a friend who got shot
and i don't remember where but i know he
got uh honorably discharged after going
to the army when he graduated due to
complications to his gunshot so wow
there was that
okay and i mean as far as things that
follow you from that like i can't if i
go to a busy restaurant you better
believe my back's against the wall i
want to see everybody that comes in
that's that old mafia [ __ ] yeah
and i still if i go to the bathroom and
somebody walks in behind me i'm like ugh
you know i got to kind of keep an eye
you just never know you never know did a
gig have you ever done have you ever
been to chicago no i did a gig in
chicago and then they took me over to
the al capone's old place called the
green mill and it's just it's vintage
it's as if it's untouched like 50s 60s
it's just gorgeous and i was like you
guys should do a show here they go we do
every sunday afternoon and it's been
sold out forever and i was like [ __ ]
yeah it's gorgeous and they go that's
capone's seat over there so we go sit in
the booth and then as soon as you sit in
the booth you can see why it's his booth
okay he's got an exit right behind him
but he can see everything it's not even
facing front it's facing it's in the
middle so he's got his right and his
left but nothing behind him but a door
and it's this beautiful booth and you're
like oh that's the [ __ ] yeah that's
where out exactly always know where the
exits are just in case you know
so can we talk let's go to this i want
to try to stay chronologically now so
you meet with this group of people at
the school sure rumors are flying every
once you hear who it is
uh we talk about the people i'm sure who
die what's next how long does school
close like when do you actually go back
and what are you doing in that time one
thing i want to point out in the parking
lot there was a trip man was so the
whole school was pretty much there in
the parking lot parents are showing up
because they're being reunited and if
you you can google 10 o'clock in the
morning too yeah
it's all it's all documented it's on
that you can find it on on google if you
look it up there's news footage and
everything you can see them gathering in
that area
parents were coming to reunite with
their kids unfortunately some of the
parents came found out that their kids
were no longer alive that's really sad
and you see that i didn't see that no
the shooter's dad
comes looking for his son hey
is he okay i don't want to say his name
is he okay asking his friend so he saw
like oh no i think he did it
imagine the dad goes there thinking that
his son was you know a victim that he's
the one that caused all this
so that happened in the parking lot that
was part of where everybody was reunited
after that it was just i don't remember
too much in that day it didn't hit me
what happened until later that night
a radio station a real popular radio
station down there
was talking about it and i was like wow
this station's playing it you know and
that's when
geraldo rivera had you know come down by
then all the big names were there and
you realized how massive it actually was
yeah i mean my god what point do you all
uh as a community find out that this
parent and these kids knew
i don't i remember it being almost
immediately yeah almost immediately man
so i know that there was some burnouts
he was hanging out with and he said he
was gonna he was gonna shoot the school
up and this one kid specifically i
remember because i went to elementary
school with them huge loser right
i think he was already dropped out of
high school by this time and he told the
kid who did the shooting you're not
gonna do it you're a [ __ ]
egging him on next day he does it no no
no repercussions for him by the way i
don't know what happened to him i'm sure
he's in prison but for something else
but
just you know escalated
unnecessarily so how long is school
closed before you get to go back one day
that's it yeah you get the [ __ ] out of
here today
one day
how's it not closed for like two weeks a
month that's what we thought we thought
oh we're gonna be out of school for a
long time that was the rumor because you
know we didn't want to go back to school
anyway would you who would want to i'd
be scared to go back the next day yeah i
don't think it was shorter
i was gonna say i'm sure the absentee
rate that day was up they i know that i
walked on campus the first day back
you haven't even processed this no you
really haven't man it's not it's 24
hours later you're back in the building
where you just
almost got killed yourself where people
you know have been maimed and some have
been murdered yes and you're walking
that same hallway and seeing these same
bullets yeah everybody's retracing their
steps from that day i remember walking
on the campus it was the quietest i've
ever heard it you know everybody was
there but very few people talking it was
just really eerie
and then you know it wasn't we had uh
counselors in every class so counselors
came in and it was that way
for a while i forget how long but they
were there every day taking over the
class we weren't learning we were
talking about what happened and then
they put uh they put in like a makeshift
building
for campuses for uh counselors that were
there the rest of the time i was in high
school i don't know how long they stayed
but i'm sure the teachers everyone the
faculty everyone needed to talk to
somebody after some [ __ ] like that yeah
yeah
[ __ ] the bathroom never reopened as long
as i was there they always kept it shut
you guys know there are all these
gimmicks that promise a great night's
sleep out there right i don't care what
kind of toppers they are or heavy a
blanket maybe it's just lipstick on a
pig if you're sleeping on a terrible
mattress your sleep will be terrible
it's that simple that's why i recommend
sleeping on a purple mattress that's
because only purple mattresses have the
gel flex grid it's a super stretchy
ultra squishy material that adapts and
flexes around pressure points and
doesn't retain heat all right unlike
memory foam which remembers everything
thanks to the gel flex grid purple
mattresses bounce back as you move and
shift and you'll never have that i'm
stuck feeling people get with memory
foam purple sent me a pillow same
technology and i'm a side sleeper i love
it i it readjusts it doesn't like you
know have a
cave in it every time i put my face on i
don't have to lift it up in the middle
of night and fluff it and turn it over
and everything it keeps its shape it's
awesome try your purple mattress risk
free with free shipping and returns
financing is available too getting a
great night's sleep starts with having a
great mattress get a purple mattress go
to purple.com honeydew and use code
honeydew for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com honeydew code honeydew for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
honeydew promo code honeydew terms apply
you guys know i believe in mental health
this show has become a mental health
show to be honest and i know a lot of
people are embarrassed to go i know a
lot of people feel like i'm it's not
manly it's not listen man all that's cr
it's garbage get that out of your head
right now okay meeting with the
therapist to work on your mental health
it's just as helpful as hiring a
personal trainer to work on your
physical health and the positive impact
can be just as life-changing talkspace
makes it possible to speak with a
licensed therapist right from your phone
tablet or computer and unlike
traditional therapy you can message your
therapist anytime via text video or
voice it's a 100 secure and stigma free
the way therapy should be at talkspace
your privacy and security are their
number one priority the app puts you in
a private room with just you and your
therapist and you can send messages 24 7
and get replies throughout the day no
need to wait for a weekly appointment
talk spaces encryption and added
security features keep your conversation
fully protected join talkspace today and
start moving forward with a single
message just visit talkspace.com and
you'll get a hundred dollars off your
first month when you use the promo code
honeydude signup that's a hundred bucks
off at talkspace.com
promo code honeydude do it for yourself
today now let's get back to the do did
they flags half-mast what sort of any
scholarships in these kids names what do
they do to remember these kids i don't
remember that i do know that they had a
bunch of vigils the community really got
behind them they had churches where we'd
have the memorials for them i remember
going to the memorial they had a like a
big big church everybody went there for
the memorial and i lived close so i
walked walking home remember it was the
first time i cried i was gonna ask yeah
that was the only time the first time i
cried why what made you cry at that i
think just realizing how innocent the
two kids were that died i don't think i
was so scared about myself i think it
was just it was so sad that these you
know their parents got up there and
spoke about what they wanted to do that
one kid wanted to be a
uh
stunt man yeah and the other kid wanted
to go into the
army and his
grandpa was so proud of him because he
was gonna be a captain or go further
than he actually did just hearing the
stories real you know putting because i
didn't know him personally
putting you know personality to these
actual people you know these were actual
kids that lived and now that and i still
think about them to this day thinking
you know they all this all this they've
missed all this for nothing for nothing
absolutely never where they were
supposed to be yeah they weren't even
[ __ ]
[ __ ] off or out doing illegals they
were no
doing nothing wrong i always say two of
the most innocent kids at the school i
mean they were just you know they
weren't jerks everybody i knew had
nothing but kind things to say about
these kids so tell me about two weeks
later what happens how does that happen
two weeks later
saying is he is the shooter involved
with your shooter or in that circle no
people just it was the type of cat
crimes which were that was a new term at
the time i remember copycat crime and
that's exactly what it was i think it
was so close to home and i don't know i
mean it was everywhere you couldn't get
away from it so within the whole san
diego area
i'm guessing he was he had problems too
and he ended up killing himself in
prison so no no what happened to you
yeah how many people died in that i
don't think anybody died
actually nobody died at granite hills i
know we shot some kids but none of them
died luckily
okay
so um
can we shift a little bit to well tell
me a little more like you had a full
year to go after that yeah you know what
i feel normal after that ever it got
back to normal everything went back to
normal like i said there was a lot of
fighting going on beforehand for a while
i'd say a week or so you know
everybody's sympathetic towards
everybody's knees and then they just
went back normally you know you forget
to move on yeah real fast maybe longer
in the week a couple weeks but at least
a couple months i don't remember being
an issue
sorry i think it was february so
pretty much a couple months and then
boom it's back to normal and then you
get out then your summer hits yeah and
then you just go back the next year and
yeah i don't remember any difference you
know not a lot of kids transfer [ __ ]
where are you going to transfer the
other schools getting shot up too
yeah exactly you know it was safe yeah
i'll never forget the yearbook that came
out that year they were selling ebay was
still new they were selling them on ebay
because the shooter and one of the the
shooter was a freshman and one of the
kids he killed was a freshman and they
were on the same page in the yearbook
they never took his picture out
yeah so that people were bidding for
that on ebay
unbelievable unbelievable
yeah i still have that yearbook man
you do yeah
uh i don't think i've i don't actually
don't think i've looked at it since
since then but i know i still have it
okay so
um tell me about without naming this
piece of [ __ ] tell me about this guy now
you say he goes to prison
and like how why do you guys do you get
updates on this person yeah yeah
somebody
used to cover
san diego used to cover in their in the
union tribune which is the paper out
there so you were always getting updates
like hey he's appealing his case hey he
wants to go up hey here's what he looks
like now because he was he was a
freshman he was small and he grew
i don't know he's really tall now really
big guy to me he looks like a monster
looks like an absolute monster now look
at look at him for yourself tell me i'm
wrong but i think he looks like a
monster anyway he was a small kid
and they think that's why he was that's
what everybody the news was pushing is
hey he did it because he's a small kid
also guess what you didn't do this for
racially motivated or bullying or
anything you did it to be with the
people you wanted to run with and those
people are in prison why do you want to
get out stay there you put yourself
exactly where you want to be you
[ __ ]
you're with the homies stay there
[ __ ]
well i don't know much about him other
than he grew within that first year that
was the big story he's like look he's so
much bigger now and you know he would
have been prison roy i'm sure yeah
all i know is that he came from
somewhere on the east coast from a small
town and then came to our city and it
was he had trouble fitting in that's all
i know other than that his mom was on
the east coast his dad moved out here
and he lived with his dad there's
actually footage that they have
where he filmed something on a camera
and he was going through his apartment
before the school shooting and he
pans across the his dad's gun cabinet
and he goes oh there's the no-no
cabinet it keeps going so that's one of
the reasons that the dad didn't go to
jail because he has proof that the guns
were locked up
so it's just and he educated his son
that you don't touch those yeah i guess
and then a couple months later because
the video was only a few months old
you know it surfaces around that's when
he did the shooting but you can see he's
interesting he's a minor so yeah so his
father could go to prison huh because it
was his dad's 22 yeah it was his dad's
gun luckily and by the way luckily it
was a 22. you're right and not a [ __ ]
uh ar or something she's never
well you're right i think about i mean
you made such a great point about cattle
literally just packed in these hallways
and that's somebody there they don't
need to aim you're right they can just
spray into that [ __ ] crowd without
even making it personal and that's all
he was doing man never forget how loud
that was in the hall does it echo in the
hallway just because if you go to a gun
range and you shoot indoors it's loud it
is very if you go in a hallway that's
just enclosed like that i mean i've
never heard anything that loud it was
unbelievable
and
um
do honest to god i want to ask you this
because firecrackers sound a lot on 4th
of july do you ever does it ever trigger
you at all firecrackers don't normally i
know that that's what a lot of people
thought it was at first i'm sure yeah
those firecrackers sound similar because
you don't process it's going to be a
shootout yeah that's the first time it
comes to your mic especially especially
also back then yeah you know back then
nowadays maybe they're i know they have
new drills and [ __ ] i never had when i
so that one asked you were there any
new safety precautions put in uh new
drills new anything that you had to go
through after this no not that i
remember no drills
no new drills other than that
it was it was pushed to be security
wasn't beefed up yeah they did have some
security we did have yeah we'd have more
police on campus they also had weapons
now yeah so they went with yeah police i
remember more police presence and then
how did you feel about more police
presence oh we were all for it okay yeah
you know to me i felt safer at that time
we all did did the students have a say
no no
it's funny because you get these school
shootings now when people are all over
the news or all over social media we
just had a short window to get our voice
out there and then it was gone right you
know it's just crazy and i think that's
why people forget about it we didn't
have social media to really keep it
going and keep everything alive
yeah the internet at that point is what
five six years old yeah
um so you told me before we started
recording that you
um
started doing an after school um was it
after school program yeah was that an
after-school program after you graduated
yeah after i
graduated probably 26. you stayed in
sort of the school system
yeah i never thought about that but i
was in so this after school program was
for the elementary school elementary
still in the same school district that
the high school was in
i worked this after school program and i
hear whispers that there's a girl there
that i work on as i was subbing in these
different places i was just kind of
using it for extra money and i had a
long term sub at a specific school and i
hear rumors that a girl who works there
is dating
the killer who's in prison right now
she's dating him in prison from prison
from prison like a new relationship
since he's been in there meaning
post-murder meaning she knew everything
about him and decided to date the guy
yeah and now she's working how's that as
i'm saying how's that not a conflict of
interest i don't know the same school
district and i was nervous yes and i was
nervous because i was thinking what is
she going to say man i'm going to lose
it on her i'm going to absolutely lose
it on her i'm going to do something
stupid
lose my job
she never brought it up
and i think that's why i i despised
looking at her i didn't i would never
talk to her i wouldn't you know um but i
people were telling me before i went
there or as i was there that hey you
know that's his girlfriend and uh
i've heard my brother told me my brother
actually worked there he was telling me
that she would go around saying i'm so
excited this weekend i get to go see my
boyfriend
what yeah
and that's what bothered me more than
anything because i think if i hear that
i don't know what i'm going to say back
to her
and i need this job
yeah that was one of the ones that was
one of the worst i would say that's one
of the worst
that was one of the worst things going
through after the school shooting
because just it just brought up so much
so much pain and then knowing that this
girl was okay because i to me the guy's
dead i could care less
[ __ ]
i don't know i don't know i don't
understand people like that
so can you talk to me about some of the
traumas you've uh suffered from this and
what you maybe still deal with
definitely uh i would say
crowds of people bother me
like just where are you where are we
talking about like like a
yeah coachella bother anything concerts
bother me
anywhere where there's not a clear exit
so i know if we're gonna get if we try
to escape there's gonna be a bunch of
people going that same direction i don't
like using public restrooms i do but i
don't like using public restrooms like
the urinals when people i can hear
people behind me that bothers me if i'm
in a restaurant my back's against the
wall
things like that so it does stay and for
a while i i didn't like i couldn't go
into an enclosed school so if we had an
indoor school i had a hard time walking
through those hallways and a few times i
had to for whatever reason yeah because
the outdoor schools and look they were
new to me we didn't we weren't even
allowed outside oh okay you know we had
harsh winters and [ __ ] too maryland but
you didn't get to go outside you just
went through the hall of your next class
and stuff there was no hanging outside
um until after school with like sports
and [ __ ] like that right you didn't get
to but like literally there was no way
to you had to exit a door to get out of
the building where i walk my kids
campuses and you can just [ __ ] run
right over there and be out somewhere
else you know i think if i were a parent
i would look for that i would want there
to be an outside campus just yeah more
ways to get out because i can't imagine
what it would have looked like had he
been indoors and you know there's only
one or two exits luckily there was
throughout the campus you could find
ways out and i think that's that helped
other than uh other than there only
being one shooter and him not following
staying in that one area
i guess when he got i meant to bring
this up earlier but when the
cops got there
he threw his gun down and he put his
hands out the window and said oh it's
just me
out the window the school oh sorry not
out the window out the door oh out the
door of the bathroom so it's just
meaning i'm the only shooter but meaning
i don't know how he meant it dear old
just little little me is how i took it
okay it's just just me i don't think he
even thought about
what he had done you know what i mean
and later there was news footage of him
later that night being taken into
custody and that's the only time i saw
him cry so i know he wasn't crying it
you know when he was arrested
jesus christ
um okay i want to ask you this because
you
stayed sort of teaching for a little
while
um where do you stand on second
amendment are you a gun owner i am yes i
am a gun owner i'm for it
were you were you
and your family prior to the school
shooting no
no
you think without the school shooting
you would
i don't know you know i don't know it's
definitely i know how helpless you can
feel in a situation like that
and after that i knew i wanted something
i just never wanted to feel that
helpless again if i could help it and
the only place i could do that was in my
own home
and i don't want you know i figured i've
always felt safer
yeah i don't blame you at all i mean i
grew up my father grew up hunting um so
we had guns in the house but again we
were taught
gun safety you know every gun's loaded
the safety's always off but make sure
you put it on but when you pick it up
don't [ __ ] aim it yours don't look
down it you know what i mean just like
honest to god simple [ __ ] that you're
responsible for everything that comes
out of that everything but i mean i get
both sides i understand it because
had he not had access to a gun this
never would have happened
right but unfortunately people like that
do have it so
yeah i you know
i don't
first of all i don't think any of us who
have not walked in your literal shoes in
a school shooting have any right to tell
anybody i know there's a lot of like
well i said because i said okay they
went with more guns because that's some
people were like more guns aren't the
answer
you know
maybe in that situation they are and
that's why i was curious did you feel
better sound like everybody felt way
more [ __ ] secure when you had armed
police yeah there was no complaints at
the time i can tell you that so this is
2001. nobody was complaining with the
extra cops on there and not to mention
they were all they were all armed you
know all of them and they would you know
they were spread out through the campus
and they broke up you know a lot of
there was a lot of things fights or
whatever the little riots or whatever
they had there and they were you know i
saw a lot of that minimized when that
when that presence was there so
it was a good thing for us
yeah no i'm i'm for it too i i believe
in i do believe we need to get some
sensible gun laws of course but um
you know who's who how can we sit there
and tell the the single mom that works
three [ __ ] jobs whose kids are home
has probably already been assaulted on
these goddamn streets of the united
states that she can't carry a little
something in that purse to protect
herself [ __ ] that right you know that
too
in a school shooting man
i mean thank god you're all right i i
what what
all right let me ask you this what
surprises you the most that still runs
through your head about it
probably you know what plays through my
head a lot is the stucco from the wall
hitting me yeah that when he shot in the
sound
and him hitting the soda machine just
above me for some reason that plays over
and over in my head i see that that
image and the girl the blonde girl told
you about who was going the other way
with the look on her face i'll never
forget that look
that look and then the the soda the
sound of the soda machine above me i'll
never forget that
and you said you think about those young
kids wasted lives a lot i do i think in
my way i guess in my mind it's my way of
keeping them you know
alive and it's just so to me it's so sad
so unfair what happened to them they
just didn't get a chance to have a
family or this kid's going to the
bathroom yeah yeah i can't even can't
even that's why i feel lucky that i to
be able to do comedy i think about you
know that could have been all taken from
me all the all the cool experiences i've
had just throughout life not only comedy
but throughout life and that could have
all just been taken for me that would
have been it on that day i did nothing
by 17.
yeah and
it's not your choice not that you did
anything wrong
just someone made a dumb decision is
there a like a reunion a high school
where you every time they do the high
school wait oh my yeah you did it is 20
years this year yeah we're going on 21.
holy we just have the 20th year do they
honor them and do anything for them they
do in the town i know they had
something last year i don't follow it
too much i used to get all the
information i could get on it i used to
i wanted to read everything now i don't
really want i don't want to hear much
about it you know i try and remember the
kids who were who were killed
but i don't want to really relive it
anymore there's there's documentaries of
this kid and there's there are yeah
there's people talking or he's in
documentaries
you know because they have school
shooting documentaries and someone just
told me there's one of him i don't know
how true that is
and you know 10 years ago i would have
watched it no problem now i just don't
care i don't you know i don't want to i
guess i don't want to relive it anymore
because i've noticed that
like i said the older i get the more it
bothers me i've never had an issue
i remember the
do you remember the uh what was the
school this college school shooting
where the guy was walking in 10 12 years
ago asian guy forget what virginia there
was virginia tech virginia yeah that one
was the next major one i remember that
and i could i wanted everything i want
to get all the information on all these
school shootings and then by the time
sandy hook and all that stuff came
around i just don't even follow anymore
i can't you know you said it's bothering
you more and more what is it what's
bothering you more and more specifically
uh knowing that i almost died and then
everything could have just been taken
away you know is that survivor's guilt
is that yeah there definitely is
absolutely gonna stood up on that yeah
yeah so have you uh have you gone to
therapy for it
uh
no no no never gone to therapy for it we
did have online or on campus therapy
therapists who came out that's the only
time i ever talked to somebody but see
now it's changing for you so and now i
do i want to i just haven't done it
you should go talk to somebody about
that and also i mean
i don't envy you because even talking to
a therapist they can apply whatever they
want and their knowledge and experience
but how many people have survived the
school shooting that can sit and talk to
you in a way that
you guys all i mean i hate to say all
because there's so many people these
days but all you have to
yeah you do
there's no um
or are there any grief
groups it's got to be a small select
there's never looked into that school or
the other high school or anything like
that
i know you know i got to look into that
that's a good question i don't know and
it's something i probably should
participate in to be honest not to
mention i think it's great to just raise
awareness for something like this
because it can happen it can happen
anywhere anywhere at any school at any
time i any mall any movie theater i mean
any outdoor cons that we're seeing at
every [ __ ] church i mean my god it's
yeah so it was
i really do appreciate you coming on
here and and even finding a little
uh laughter in this and um
it's an episode we've never had and
something i've never done and honestly i
hope i never have to do another episode
like this sure i get it you know no
thanks for listening i'm just glad that
we can get the story out there i hope i
didn't talk too fast
when all the memories come in i start
rushing you were great i've been through
it so i appreciate it of course now i
ask every guest their first time here
and this is going to be interesting i
asked them because this happened when
you were 17 yeah so advice you would
give to your 16 year old self knowing
what you know now you know what i
actually thought about this not too long
ago do you remember going to school with
those kids that were maybe loners didn't
have any friends maybe something was a
little off the kids that didn't have
their hair comb they just
sweatpants
something was going on at home and you
didn't realize that as a kid right
something was up maybe maybe the kid was
off maybe it wasn't maybe there was
something going on at home if i could go
back and talk to my 16 year old self 17
year old self i would say go up to those
kids who you see alone every day
make a point to just say hello
say hi ask them how their day is going
because i bet you
10 20 years from now it's going to mean
the world to them nobody took the time
to talk to those kids and i i don't know
for some reason i really regret that you
know it really bothers me that's great i
tell my daughter all the time i'd rather
be a better friend than a student
you know i just had a parent-teacher
conference on
what the hell was it thursday or friday
last week and i right away it was like
how is she as a french like awesome she
loves everybody so i was like let's not
hug over here we got a pandemic you know
i tell my daughter to fist bump for
crazy
i agree yeah i think it's better to be a
better friend yeah
absolutely thank you so much no that
wasn't easy i appreciate it you were
great you there's you don't apologize
for anything uh but one more time please
plug and promote everything you'd like
so i'm at steven garza joke for
instagram if you can check out my
youtube stephen garza comedy all right
brother we'll stay safe out there and
you all stay safe out there as well i am
ryan sickler
talk to y'all next week
you